what do you think about
Bitcoin then
do you think it's one of those
communities that does attack you when
criticized so which I guess which coins
do you think are open to criticism and
which are not it's kind of tough like
Community is a monolith so just like
it's just a spectrum of how open they
are there's just like there's always
this core contingent of extreme
believers who will go after anyone who
criticizes them and it's just about how
wide of a band that makes up of the
entire token how intensely how active
that small community is correct so it's
in Bitcoin they're called Bitcoin
maximalists yes but you can also call
any any communities subgroup like that
maximalist whatever the belief is right
I don't know uh Dunkin Donuts Maximus uh
that Community is probably small in
terms of attack you online if you could
you know which Community has a very
intense
following so
I got attacked on the internet when I
said Messi's better than Ronaldo
oh yeah that's controversial and so
that's a very intense maximalist
Community there uh the other one that
surprised me is when I said
now I did it ingest okay folks I said
emacs is a better ID than Vim I love
emacs I agree
listen I have trauma I wake up sweating
sometimes at night thinking Max Master
is the the Vim the Vim people are after
me they're everywhere they're in the
shadows no Vim isn't amazing and it's
actually surprised I've recently learned
that it's
um still even more so than before an
incredibly active community so a lot of
people wrote but do you use space Max
it's just emacs and Vim no I haven't I
use raw
um but but so you got to use yeah hold
on a second I actually recently I have
recently said you know what
um Let's Make Love Not War and I went to
vs code
I uh I went to a more modern idea but uh
because I did most of my program emacs I
did most of anything as one does an
emacs just because I also love lisp so I
can customize everything then I realized
like
like how long will vim and emacs be
around really well I was thinking as a
programmer
looking like 10 20 years out
you know I should challenge myself to
learn new ideas to learn uh the the new
tools that the majority of the community
is using so that I can understand what
are the benefits of the cost I found
myself getting a little too comfortable
with the tools that I've grew up with
sure I think one of the fundamental ways
of being as a programmer is anyone
involved with technology
based on how quickly it's evolving is to
keep learning new tools like the way of
life should be constantly learning
you're not a mathematician or a
physicist or any of those disciplines
that are more stable this is like
everything's changing cryptos like you
said a perfect example that you have to
constantly update your understanding of
the of of digital Finance constantly in
order to be able to function in order to
be able to criticize it uh in order to
be able to know what to invest in so
yeah that that was why I did uh I tried
pie charm a bunch uh the whole jetbrains
uh uh infrastructure and then also vs
code because that's really popular I
mean you know Adam and um uh Sublime of
those I've been I've been exploring I've
been exploring UCS code is amazing you
should check out space Max I'm just
going to give one more pitch for it it's
just basically like a customizable
customizable configuration well emacs is
already customizable but it's uh
it's pretty useful I'm not even much of
a coder but for like certain journaling
applications or like time management
like I find it really useful so
but anyway we're so like in I feel like
half this podcast is what it should have
been and half of it's just us nerding
out about our own engineering like
idiosyncrasies sorry sorry guys uh all
right so what were we talking about safe
Moon
and Bitcoin Bitcoin what do you think is
there uh
have you made enemies in certain
communities what do you think about
Bitcoin so
I've made certain enemies in the sort of
crypto Skeptics space because there's
sort of this range of skepticism you can
have about cryptocurrency I'm obviously
a skeptic of a lot of it
um but
there are certain aspects of crypto that
I think are inevitable and I'm gonna do
my best to kind of describe those here
but I'm not committed to any crypto
specifically but there's some I've taken
a lot of heat ironically for not being
skeptical enough there's some people who
believe that like the entire thing is a
complete waste of time their uh r slash
but coin on Reddit it's an amazing
Community actually it's very funny they
have what's a book it's like is it it's
like a play on bitcoin they're like oh
they're just like oh at least we admit
it's a scam very funny guys uh very
funny people there so but they like but
they'll they'll be like you know
coffee's Alicia just admit that all of
it's a giant Ponzi scheme all of it's a
basically like not real so everything
including Bitcoin include yeah it's all
it's all basically all the Ponzi nomics
it's all it's it's ponzienomics all the
way down it's like there is no
fundamental use case that uh is that
useful I don't know if I guess I don't
want to straw man them here I don't want
to say that I don't know if they're
saying that it's all useless at minimum
they're saying the level of interest in
cryptocurrencies is far the actual
usefulness of it is far less than the
amount of attention and time and money
that's being poured into it so like the
revolutionariness of this technology is
not at all revolutionary let me kind of
Steal man what I think the pro crypto
take is
I think
that
Technologies are sort of this inert
thing and the success of them in my
opinion is not based on PR it's not
based on marketing it's based on cheaper
faster better
fundamentally the success of any
technology relies on those three things
and longevity of it
so I have two employees and both of them
are out of the country so I have to
frequently make international wire
payments to them
um is one of them SBF just um as a
reporter I have to ask no okay all right
um he's not an apparel yeah I think he'd
have to pay me I'm trying to do my best
coffee Zillow where it's like an
hard-headed investigative questions good
so with these International payments you
face all sorts of slow
fees and you you face like kind of like
this time thing and it's this painful
process
so
if I use different cryptocurrencies some
of them are like really fast some of
them have really low fees I just believe
in a world where
digital currencies with fast payments
with cheap payments revolutionize
the global exchange of currency and I
don't know if this if this is going to
include the blockchain
it's just that the blockchain is the
first thing that's really embraced truly
digital currency which doesn't need to
go through this complicated system of
wire transfers and just happens so I can
send you let's say I want to send you
ethereum or Bitcoin I can send it to you
just as fast if I send you a dollar
or a billion dollars and I can send it
to you just as fast if you're across
from me or if you're across the world
from me that I think is a step change
and easier faster better in terms of
like just this really basic
International payments kind of idea so I
think at like its core if the the lowest
form use case of cryptocurrencies is
that I think it will
um change the world in some variety it's
just kind of the larger question is is
that gonna is that technology going to
include the blockchain specifically
or not the other benefit is transparency
which I personally like as an
investigator it's just that
previously it's like hard to describe
how opaque our financial system is until
you've tried to investigate someone or
something
understanding finances unless you have a
subpoena unless you're like the FBI or
like the SEC and you can get a subpoena
for someone's finances or you're going
through Discovery you don't know what
someone has you're basically playing
poker with everyone and the cards are
face down
For the First Time The blockchain to
some extent because there are ways to
obfuscate it and in some ways
cryptocurrency has enabled more fraud
which is kind of this irony but in some
ways it's enabled people to also audit a
lot better and in real time and I think
that is a structural change
that is fundamentally for the better
the question of all this is do those
Bettors outweigh the cons that this
introduces and how much can those can
regulation mitigate those cons some of
those cons being like fraud money
laundering all these negative
externalities that are easier with
cryptocurrency what do you think
cryptocurrency in particular seems to
attract
fraudulent people uh like uh scammers
and because it Fosters because it's
unregulated it's the wild west and you
can transmit large amounts of money very
quickly across the world what about with
very little oversight creating new
crypto projects like uh new coins uh
because you have to show very little
actual use case you can just promise
this is like true of any emerging
technology so much vaporware happens at
the beginning when it's all promise
because fundamentally let's say you're
legitimate I'm illegitimate
we look the same at the start of a
technology because both of us are
promising what this can do and in fact
the less Scruples and morals I have in
some ways I can out-compete you because
I can say mine does what Lexus does but
like way better and way faster and it's
going to happen in a year rather than 10
years you're being honest I'm playing a
dishonest game I look better once this
space matures and you actually have some
people actually doing the things that
they say they're going to do suddenly
this equation changes now your Amazon
you're delivering in two days I can say
whatever I want
you do the thing you do and I have no
credibility so I think the like part of
part of the fraud is you know just the
ability to transmit so much money so
quickly with such little oversight part
of it is like this just happens with any
emerging technology vaporware is a real
thing and hopefully as the space matures
as regulation comes in
things will improve